he's been calling Nets games for 25
years but if if he doesn't mind me
saying I do believe he did win the sixth
annual marty glickman award for
leadership in sports media because he
reads a Madame secretary promo like
nobody else in the business
these irony GLE how are you iron rich
thank you thank you so much the promo
that's what it's all about the football
is filler for the promos God's friended
me congratulate you know what I earn I
do believe God has friended you you know
every time I say it I think that I'm not
to get too deep not to get to dinner but
um you are blessed you certainly aren't
blessed how you been how's it going
everything's great everything's very
first of all congratulations to you and
your crew okay gob you did in London
Oh was off the charge Thank You
impressive wow that is not easy first of
all when you have a booth that is as
large as that one as you now know yes
the gantry [ __ ] I have no idea how you
all fit in the booth literally that's
not a big booth and then to just step in
and do play-by-play the way that you did
was tremendous the chemistry was great
it was a really enjoyable thank you I
and that means a lot coming from you
especially and yeah I think they did
remove some part of the gantry as they
refer to it at Wembley to fit us all all
for you four men in a and a broadcast
booth but a man that's why I mean it's
so much fun to do that I've been waiting
for a long time to call an NFL game and
you know so and you bring the enthusiasm
as always to it's so much fun it really
really is yeah and also to handle it in
a four man booth that very easily could
have been naked gun with Joyce brothers
and it wasn't it moved it worked
everybody knew their place it was really
enjoyable that's right the Naked Gun
booth I think had Mel Allen dick
vitality and
berg was in there too right and bert jim
palmer I believe is believe it or not
yes that was funny because people were
referring do that and I'm like I just
hope the Queen doesn't show up because
Reggie Jackson's here that could be a
big problem oh my gosh all right let's
talk let's talk football first which
gave me doing this week you just did the
Jets and the Patriots what do you have
this week yeah I've got Thursday on the
radio okay Allison Harlan says still
wear makeup just because every case and
then Sunday I've got the Kansas City
Chiefs and the Oakland Raiders okay so
let me start with the macro question the
best team you've laid eyes on personally
through the first dozen weeks would be
which yeah look I had the Rams early I
had the Chiefs the first two weeks yet
to see New Orleans in person other than
every season I had them against the
Chargers in the preseason week three
game I know how good they are and I knew
how good they were just watching them
that day even in the preseason you think
to yourself they have so many weapons
and I obviously knew that Mark Ingram
wasn't going to be there the first floor
which it didn't matter
this team is stacked and the the real
question to me is just going to be
defensively for the Rams the Chiefs and
the Saints who at this point are on a
different level than the other teams in
the NFL New England is in that next year
I think the Chargers are in that next
year Pittsburgh that was a hit last week
against Denver but I still think the
Steelers will get things together and
they'll be a force to be reckoned with
come playoff time and then in the NFC
you've got this secondary grouping that
includes Dallas and I am not sure yet on
the Cowboys I'm very curious to see how
they handle themselves this week to me
New Orleans has the most potential
defensively they've had a bunch of
playmakers I think Dennis Allen's done a
very good job with this group the Chiefs
have the most questions defensively and
then the Rams they got a bunch of big
names they're getting to lead back I
like the back
that Los Angeles has on that side of the
ball and I think when the smoke clears
it's LA and it's New Orleans in the NFC
yeah I know and I think you you you
touched on that their iron about the
game that's coming up on Thursday that
you're calling on the radio is the
Cowboys are feeling it they're feeling
it right now then you're hearing the
sound bytes coming out of their DeMarcus
Lawrence we cannot play for a family
audience how he essentially said I can
clean it up is that all you got to do is
just get in the face of a high-flying
offense and frustrate them and they
might disintegrate and and you know dak
saying we put our pants on one leg at a
time just like that you know and I think
that that's you're getting the censored
out this could be a moment where Dallas
does want to throw its had in that first
to your ring this this could be a
seminal moment for them Elliott is
running a football like the guy that we
saw in his rookie year and I think
they've gotten back to it they've gotten
back to who they are and maybe it took
the Amari Cooper transaction for them to
get a better understanding of how they
had to win games and how they had to run
their offense offensive line has looked
better again has looked like a dominant
group in recent weeks it defensively
it's fun fun watching Leighton Zander
he's grown all over the field what a
great story fantastic story you know
you're doing research and you're trying
to jot down notes and you realize that
he went to a high school that had a
graduating class of 11 11 they had
enough for one offense or one defense in
fact they didn't play regular football
they played seven on seven eight on
eight in high school so he averaged
twenty six point seven points per game
as a senior in high school on the
basketball team but they had eleven
students like one person didn't make the
team basically it's it's pretty amazing
and I give Jason Garrick credit a rich I
don't know how many times you've been
forced to talk about this because it's a
legitimate story than being on the hot
seat and every single time he seems to
come through and rally his team and get
them together when it matters most
an eagle here on the Rich Eisen show
have you called Mayfield have you seen
him personally yet yeah yeah we we did
Hugh Jackson's finale by the way Hugh
Jackson's finale is a great album I
think that was I think that was oh yeah
78 yeah finale huge axis finale was was
i think i think was acoustic Hugh
Jackson's phonetic who's dick and they
just didn't even want to go into the
studio and put all the electrics it was
perfect the way it was awesome he it's
funny because we look back now on that
meeting and Dan Fouts asked him in the
meeting he said well you've got Baker
Mayfield why aren't you running more of
the stuff that he ran at Oklahoma oh yes
one pass option stuff and you said yeah
question I agree this is well what's the
answer
oh my I agree and we walk out of there
thinking what is going on here and
obviously that was the end of the line
they lose that game Baker was great in
the sit down we were really impressed
and myself Evan Washburn our production
team we walked out of there thinking wow
this guy has legitimate leadership
qualities but there was something amiss
even in some of our questions regarding
the offense regarding Todd Haley
regarding Hugh Jackson and we were not
shocked when they made the decision that
just seemed to be complete disorganized
chaos behind the scenes and now they
they got a little something going and
Cleveland Houston is a huge so much fun
it's so much fun him versus deshaun
Watson would have been you know a Fowler
Herbstreit game to two years ago right
exactly and and here we go I can't wait
to watch something like that but what
does that mean I agree does that mean
I'm sorry it's like what that mean
that he was actually against it but knew
that he had to tell you the answer you
were looking for because he wanted to be
he didn't want like say you and and
hall-of-famer like Fouts to think that
he was
or yeah or or not Mike or was it really
an internal struggle that the head coach
was losing I mean what does that mean
yeah my sense was he was basically
trying to say to Dan that yes we should
be doing that but we're not and that was
you remember on the heels of him
questioning Todd Haley in the press
conference post game the week before
right then came out and said no no we've
met where we're good everything's cool
well it wasn't cool and it wasn't good
and then the state's got raised another
level when he signed on what Cincinnati
and Baker at his reaction this week just
a lot of soap opera stuff unnecessary
distractions huge seems to find himself
in the middle of all that he might be
the head coach of the Bengals when the
smoke clears so this thing could carry
on for another three to five years in
the AFC North but yeah I've been around
this thing long enough to know when even
in these production meetings which
sometimes are wrote but other times you
do get some insight and it's not even
something that you necessarily have in
terms of a quote form it's just more of
a vibe and the vibe there was this thing
was a sinking ship and I kneel here on
the Rich Eisen show one last one for you
so you're doing the Chiefs you're going
to the black hole and so mahomes he is
just awesome
he's just so much fun to watch and it
looks like they're getting Eric Barry
back to me we had a poll question
yesterday the team that could beat the
Chiefs the biggest threat to the Chiefs
and we named all of the the suspects
that you would think ah I said it's
themselves they're a game in front
they've got this kid mahomes is red-hot
Andy Reid is is red-hot say with be
enemy whatever they're doing whatever
they're cooking up and Barry comes back
all they have to do is just plain play
clean sheet football and I think they
get everybody coming to down their house
what would I say you know rich and I
think a big part of that is what we
talked about at the top defensively if
they can be competitive if they can be
opportunistic Barry could be such a
difference maker for them but it's
asking a lot remember he played one game
last year they had a ruptured Achilles
so the fact that he's even coming back
we had no idea what he would be he is
yet to play a snap in 2018 so I don't
want to push it too far with Barry and
how that changes the the balance of
things in the AFC I just know that
mahomes has not come down to earth and I
don't know if he ever will come back
down to earth he has led such a charmed
existence in his first year as a starter
and you sit down and you meet with him
you can't help but be impressed and
really confident but there's this humble
side he understands that he understands
how to interact with his teammates I
don't necessarily think he's stand up in
the front of the room and and scream out
how he's going to lead and how he's
going to do this it's more of a quiet
leadership but one-on-one interaction
with his guys it's been really strong
and everybody is bought in he's he's the
real deal Andy Reid's got so many toys
to work with the enemy that's worked
it's a it's a really fun enjoyable
experience to just sit back and watch
the Kansas City Chiefs run their offense
so let's turn to hoops one a few minutes
we have left with UI on Eagle you're
calling Utah at the Brooklyn Nets
tonight in your 25th year calling
Brooklyn or Mets basketball and eight
and 13 the nets are vastly improved that
would be that would be 15th place in the
Western Conference but in the East that
puts them in the hunt
watch which is the best team you've seen
through the first quarter of the NBA
season best team that I've seen that's a
that's a great question because I don't
know if I've seen them yet personally we
have Toronto coming up on the schedule I
think they're really good and Kawhi
Leonard has certainly brought a edge to
that team and he is motivated I don't
know what's gonna happen if he's going
to be with the Raptors long term if they
convince him that this is the right spot
for him but it's certainly the right
spot for now coming off the san antonio
experience and we've seen a little bit
of a back-and-forth Popovich came out
and mentioned that Kawhi was not a
natural leader Leonard went back a bit
and he's not going to engage necessarily
in a back and forth but
it's just been a really good fit they
needed to make a change
DeMar DeRozan they went as far as they
could go with him
to me they're the most consistent team
in the Eastern Conference right now
Philly with Jimmy Butler really talented
chance to be a big factor come April but
right now still a work in progress
Boston is working through some things
right now look Golden State is who they
are
and when it's all out there for real and
the playoffs come around I expect them
to be front and center but some of the
stuff has has been percolating and the
fact that it spilled over with draymond
Green and Kevin Durant not to say that's
going to stop them from winning a
championship but it just gave you a
little brief inkling of what's going on
behind the scenes there and it's not
smooth terrain right now for Steve
Curren company and that happens with
championship teams and egos and
contracts and free agency that's not
shocking but it did give you a glimpse
that they're dealing with with a little
bit of drama there all right I know by
the way I've just been told by fellow
Syracuse orange man Chris Brockman my
honor compadre that James Dolan's JD in
the straight shot is covering Hugh
Jackson's oh yeah I believe at the
bottom line in the village tonight you
want to hop over from Brooklyn after the
game it was missing the harmonic risk
yeah he's gonna put his own spin on it
you know yeah okay so so when when I
watch Chiefs Raiders and you do the
promo for God friended me I know I know
that's like the caliber net tug on the
year for me know got rated you Congrats
again and I'll be thinking of you when I
say those three words on CBS with Brent
Musburger to boots over
Ranjan himself with the Raiders ah he's
gonna be two boots over can't wait to
see him can you get
him to do the god fronted me right into
my iPhone great chat enjoy the game
tonight and travel safe all over and
thanks what you said about the London
game I mean it you guys did a great job
always great talking here we'll do it
again yeah I was about to say the best
team I've laid my eyes on are the Eagles
the pool unfortunately for me is just
Eagles and jaguars for me for us that's
all everybody the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience